all beings on this planet are affected
by atmospheric phenomena we call the
weather
systems determine when and where to
produce our food
how our infrastructure must be built to
be resilient
or when to prepare for different climate
hazards
because of this humans have invented all
sorts of measuring tools to understand
future climate conditions which lucky
for us means we have loads of data from
observations
all of this data of course has been on
quite a technology Journey
from being collected on paper to being
uploaded on local servers in basements
to being moved to open platforms that
normalize all the different data formats
from sensors into Cloud servers this has
been thanks to the labor of love of so
many that know how valuable it is to get
this information into as many hands to
find more solutions faster it's also
been incredibly challenging to compute
weather models historically these have
been physics-based this means that many
combinations are calculated in order to
simulate Natural Forces
this requires loads of expensive and
time-consuming Computer Resources
and by the time calculations are
finished it's common for weather
patterns to have changed up until
recently this has been changing by
building predictive models with a
radically different approach using an AI
technique that uses neural networks
called Deep learning in this case we use
satellite images that have labels a
phenomena to train a model to make
weather predictions
unlike traditional physics simulations
we do not need to feed it a sequence of
complex rules to calculate many weather
forces
instead neural networks are not so
literal
they take a step back and find Visual
patterns of cloud behavior from
satellite images based on past examples
this is similar to how we process
information with our eyes
here's a quick example assume we analyze
two planets they both have gravitational
pools that affect each other now add
more planets to the system there's
additional gravitational interactions to
now account for
calculating the forces between all of
them grows into exponential combinations
on the other hand training a model using
neural networks by observing the
behavior of different initial States
from a variety of planetary systems
along with what happens as the next step
it eventually helps make predictions
without having to calculate all the
forces
what's even more exciting is that such a
model can be shared with others to
generate forecasts that are nearly
instantaneous
furthermore pairing this technique with
a powerful data processing Hardware like
gpus and tpus helps users get more
accurate predictions at a fraction of
the cost and time from standard physics
simulations
this is exactly what my peers in Google
research have unlocked their model is
called metnet
it performs precipitation forecasts that
we see in the evening news at an amazing
high spatial resolution of one kilometer
within a Time resolution of two minutes
it outperforms other traditional models
that forecast up to seven to eight hours
this can help to predict extreme weather
especially as we experience further
climate changes
more specifically it can help forecast
severe rainfall in a local region within
a relatively short period
[Music]
thinking about this problem I think we
had two goals in mind one is that we
want to capture the Dynamics but in
addition we didn't want to create any
very expensive or complicated physics
and so we wanted to pursue a physics
free approach that is we want to predict
the weather purely by example we can
take examples that have been collected
from satellites and radar stations over
the last few years and use those as
examples to to train a neural network to
make predictions about the future Google
has been an excellent place to pursue
this work for many reasons one of them
is that we have scalable Cloud platforms
that make it possible to develop very
large scale models and study them on
large-scale problems the other reason is
that when we study the Earth the data
sets that we work with are large Earth
is large and if we want to work if we
want to understand the Earth at very
high resolution these are very large
data sets and they're really Out Of
Reach a person who might want to
download those data sets and use them to
study whether forecasting at home
in contrast at Google using our Cloud
platforms we can download these large
data sets and make them available to
everybody anybody who wants to study
this work and so what we've found is
that the results of our research are
useful not only to make scientific
impact but to make this technology
accessible to anyone who has the desire
to study it in honor of this awesome
data analytics problem let's see how to
approach it via an architecture diagram
we will use Google Earth engine's data
sources and Google Cloud's Computing
resources for this us-based sample we'll
use three data sets from the Google
Earth engine catalog
the first data set is goes 16 from NOAA
which stands for the National Oceanic
atmospheric Association
it collects information every 30 minutes
which is great for real-time monitoring
for weather or wildfires for example
this is possible because the go system
uses satellites stationed above the
equator and are synced to match the
Earth's orbit so it's only available in
the Americas
sure has a resolution of 2 000 meters
per pixel we'll talk about this later
the second data set is the global
precipitation measurement or GPM by NASA
it includes the amount of precipitation
measured in millimeters per hour it has
a resolution of about 10 000 meters per
pixel
and the third data set is global
elevation
next we ask ourselves what are input
data and output labels are for inputs
we'll use data from goes GPM along with
elevation for outputs which is how we
label our predictions we'll use gpm's
precipitation labels to predict the
future we pair inputs with their
respective labels together into a
training example these are where our
model will learn from
after identifying our inputs and outputs
let's export our training examples into
a training data set by using a data flow
pipeline in Google Cloud
dataflow is a data processing service
that helps speed up the export process
from hours to minutes using the Earth
engine's high volume endpoint
we typically use stratified sample to
gather a balanced amount of points per
classification but because we are
working with regression we have to
bucket our labels into classification
types
we do this by turning all our numeric
labels into integers so they all fall
into a bucket
we chose 31 buckets that represent 0 to
38 millimeters of precipitation per hour
and then for example if we choose a
hundred points for each classification
bucket and then grab a thousand random
dates
we end up with around 3 million training
examples
note we choose to make two predictions
one at two and six hours in the future
but you can make as many as desired and
in terms of the amount of inputs needed
the more pass data the better
but we have found that at least three
input points are needed to give enough
context to make any predictions in the
future
in our case we chose to feed our model
with data from the current time and at
two and four hours in the past
since we are using pytorch an ml Library
we save each training example into a
compressed numpy file format into cloud
storage next we write a script to train
the model first it splits our data set
90 10. 90 used for trading the model and
10 percent used for testing the model's
accuracy on data it has never seen
before
then we Define our model but there are
some things to consider satellite
sensors can give very large numbers but
our model prefers smaller numbers
so we create a normalization layer from
the training data set which gets your
raw inputs and normalizes them into
smaller values
then we pass the normalized inputs
through a 2d convolutional Network for
Simplicity we only use a 2d
convolutional layer followed by a 2d
deconvolutional layer each layer is
connected by a relu layer since it's a
good general purpose activation function
next we need to know what our goal is in
this case it's regression
if you are new to machine learning I
highly recommend checking out our 8
minute episode on what is deep learning
as mentioned in that episode we choose
different output activation functions
based on our goal typically for
regression we use a linear activation
function but here we can't have negative
precipitation because of this we can use
relu instead because it replaces
negative values with zero so we end up
with only non-negative values
finally we train the model in vertex Ai
and save the trained model in the pi
torch model file format into cloud
storage
we can eventually host it into Cloud run
which is a web hosting service
and finally in order to visualize our
predictions as a map we can use a
notebook like collab or we can bring it
back into Earth engine
so what's next if you would like to
review this process in Greater detail in
the description below I have included
the link to an interactive notebook with
all the code used to build this sample
it's written by two very passionate
humans on my team one is my manager
brijesh and the other is David who
co-designs this series with me you can
also find a blog post and several
helpful resources too and Community I'll
leave you with a fun fact from Jason
about the project before we end
if you found this content helpful you
can subscribe to follow us on this
journey cheers
I believe that we are at a time that's
really a turning point for our study of
our planet and the environment and the
weather and climate we also have an
unprecedented amount of information
that's available and public that you can
use to understand the Earth and we have
an opportunity to use this kind of
information
to increase our understanding of the
earth and form a kind of dialogue where
we listen to what's happening on the
earth and we make use of that in making
decisions addressing problems that are
really interesting and really important
and I feel grateful that I can do this
foreign